here's why you should never ask hey how
can I provide you value as a way to
connect with somebody I get DMS all the
time people are like hey man I just want
to find you value hey what can I do for
you you're asking me to now do the work
on your behalf to figure out how to
provide value to me I don't know
anything about your skill set I have no
background on you and you if you're
coming to me have all the context in the
world to understand the things that I
have going on in my life and so if you
actually want to provide value do the
work to provide value and make your best
bad guess even if they're left of center
if you show how much work you did on
behalf of someone else without them
asking they're way more likely to
respond to your DM maybe hop on a call
take a lunch meeting whatever then the
guys who ask hey what value can I
provide for you which is right now
nothing you've actually taken value for
me because you took my time and you
didn't give me anything